all right let's talk about spook warfare
yokai monsters or is it its yokai
monsters spook warfare yeah yokai
monsters :
boob warfare that's the English title to
this movie um the Japanese title is
probably something kind of like that
it's called the great yokai war that's
the translation the great yokai war that
all makes sense
what a yokai is in Japanese culture it's
it's like I'm a Japanese monster yeah it
means monster I think it means gobbling
goblins there or something like that or
strange creature or something like that
but you know a yokai could be anything
amongst the the Japanese pantheon of
damned monsters and they're pretty
[ __ ] weird and all the main ones are
in them in this movie yeah this is uh
has all the yokai represented like they
got a yokai that is a kapa and that he's
the main character in this or one of the
main yokai says kapa and a cop is the
thing that lives in the water and it
grabs little children's got a flat head
on it and people wondered many years if
what this was based on if a copper
really existed it did exist it was a
giant Japanese salamander that's what
they were talking about yeah some of
those things got huge you know six feet
long which is the size of a small
alligator and they would grab little
children's about the fingers and take
them underneath the water and drown them
yeah you know so something to it
salamanders are hungry man big-ass
Salamis it's an endangered species now
it's like and it's like a Japanese
national treasure another monster that's
in it is a damn umbrella monster and I
think those are called a casa Oh Bucky
Kosta Oh Bucky and that was one of the
first Japanese monsters I ever saw as a
little kid on UHF or I think it was VHF
UHF 20 channel 22 was just in outside LA
that was the local Japanese channel me
growing up as a little kid you know and
before I move away from California and I
saw one of these umbrella monsters
picture did another [ __ ] horror movie
that I had
find yet it scared the [ __ ] out of me
it's an umbrella with a single leg one
eye and a mouth of the big long talk
yeah and in arms in arms they fly around
and they poison bite people and [ __ ]
like that yeah they're bad ok and it's a
damn Japanese umbrella and I recognize
it as a little kid as one of those
little cocktail umbrella umbrellas that
you'd get no there's old 1970s drinks if
your mom used to get yeah that's true I
always I always find it really weird
that it has like that it has like a
single human leg in human arms like the
leg even has like one of those like
traditional Japanese sandals like the
yes yeah what made sense in Japanese
thinking Japanese were animal you know
traditionally yeah come on back to the
sixteen hundreds they thought the older
an object was that the more of a risk
that it might come back to life well in
your average working-class Japanese home
you know go on to the sixteen 1700s you
know the one of the most expensive items
that they owned was a damn umbrella so
an umbrella would stay in the house for
a long long time you know watching so
there was always this paranoid that that
damn umbrella might come to life because
that is the oldest thing in that yeah oh
but the way this story even got this
thing it's like a big old it's like a
big old Fox with a huge [ __ ] belly
and the belly is also a crystal ball
it'll show you like it'll show you the
future [ __ ] what's going on you know
it's a moat locations remote viewing
belly yeah one of the this movies about
and it's a good idea a Babylonian
vampire that leaves Babylon and shows up
and I guess in a toe or Tokugawa period
Japan and it's it's a vampire and it
looks kind of like that statue of Pazuzu
from wealthy that's how it looks like
possessed about this ghost yeah now I
should say like cuz I don't think we
mentioned this at the beginning but
yokai monsters spook warfare
is part of a trilogy yeah now this one
came out in 1968 there was another one
that also came out in 1968 which was
called yokai monsters 100 monsters I got
that one too I don't know yeah we have
the whole trilogy um I'm not sure like
which one cuz I thought spook warfare
was the first one and then 100 monsters
was the second one but wikipedia says it
switched but they came out the same year
and then there's another one like a
third one called
along with ghosts I think it's called
now the other two spook warfare is
pretty much yokai centric like it's
pretty much all about the monsters
whereas the other two are good but
they're more like samurai movies that
happen to have a couple of yokai in them
I don't like them as much as yeah I
don't like them as much they're not as
crazy yeah just drop acid and watch this
movie you're the weird thing about this
it's like it's weird because I didn't
find like a lot of other reviews of this
I think cinemassacre did one there were
a couple of reviews of the other two in
the series but not really this one so
much which is weird because if you love
like just batshit crazy like Japanese
cinema
yeah then you will love this [ __ ] well
but the weird thing about it that I was
going to save again reminded me when you
said the Exorcist was that the beginning
of this movie like how the Babylonian
vampire gets like unleashed I guess it's
very similar to the beginning of the
exercise however this came out several
years before the novel even it makes me
wonder if whoever shot The Exorcist
maybe had seen this movie well or yeah
or William Peter Blatty like maybe had
seen it and yeah use it because at the
beginning there's like archaeologists
and they're unearthing like the ancient
city of Ur or whatever it is and there's
like a you know there's like a statue or
like there it's it's not actually the
statue is it it's like his his staff he
has like a staff with a dragon head on
it yeah and so they kind of like just
accidentally dig him out and then all of
a sudden and then he goes to Japan for
whatever reason I guess it's tiem ah
yeah maybe it must be ten I'm thinking
about it he looks like he looks [ __ ]
crazy he doesn't look like a Western
conception of a vampire he basically has
Babylonian yeah he
I was like his his legs are like their
Eagle tat yeah their Eagle legs they're
like feathers and then he has like
talons yeah kinda like like I said looks
like something like Tia Bhat something
something you'd see on a Babylonian you
know hieroglyph or whatever you know are
you know not a hieroglyph but but they
call them what glyphs yeah or a freeze
ya know yeah something from ancient
Babylon had a weird-looking face you
know I mean kind of stereotypical
hook-nosed you know Kyle you know like
it a big like long hand head you know
yeah asian people you know stereotypical
back in the days kind of drew all white
people like that hook-nosed long head
kind of funny round eyes and [ __ ] you
know he kind of looks like an 1700s
stereotypical drawing of a westerner
yeah and he shows up with to Japan and
of course this pisses off all the
traditional Japanese monsters they can't
take this they've gotta get this [ __ ]
out because he's breaking all the
Japanese rules of the monsters in fact
they pull the rules out they Eve have
identification books how to identify and
classify other yokai monsters yeah and
they [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
and they had some good they had some
monsters in there that they also had in
Korea when I was in Korea there's a
Catoosa soldier you know we were
sleeping up on this hill at night and he
was getting closer and closer to me and
I said what are you doing Kim get off me
you know and he was scared so what you
scared him baby ghost baby ghost like I
just make it out of here I told us his
corporal corporal walk the next day said
Kim was talking about baby ghosts last
night he was oh yeah yeah so what the
[ __ ] is a baby goes you know woman they
get the baby and then they throw the
baby on the hill the good and then the
ghost comes out cries all time so it was
the ghosts of the abandoned fetuses they
are the the newborn children yes grown
up to die on the mountains almost kind
of like something out of damn Sparta
anxious this is no good I was back I
asked a friend of mine you know who he's
God makes all these little figured
Japanese figures back here I asked him
he was in Japan he's a French guy but
you know his wife his children Japanese
and I told him the Korean story of baby
ghosts and he was like yeah in Japan
it's not quite
it's in Japan it's that but the whole
throwing babies away that's not where
the baby goes came from just came from
like babies died in childbirth and
things like that that's the way they had
so I don't know where this story comes
from I think it was a fear I don't think
Kareem as far as I know Koreans did not
discard their babies at birth because of
famines or anything there's always a way
I think it was a fear that you might
have to abandon your baby or that some
people abandoned their babies I think
that's where the baby ghost myth came
from it could be although I think what
from what I was like reading about this
movie I think that the baby ghosts
looking thing in here is not actually a
baby ghost okay I think it's like a
ghost of it's called um Ana Burris
tamashii mm-hm which means oil presser
oil presser and that's like it's I guess
oil was like a big deal like back in the
day okay um and this was like the
reincarnated spirit of someone who had
stolen oil like a thief and wasn't
punished and then they have to come back
as it seems very specific only in Japan
like I should just like John umbrella
monster it's like it's a very very
specific yeah ghost it's like they don't
really have animated like other things
like they don't have like a yokai run
around it looks like a shoe no I wish
that kept long enough
she was wore out too quick the crazy
thing about this movie is that I get the
impression that it's supposed to be like
a kids movie but not because it's really
it's kind of gory for 1968 cuz the
vampire like comes in there's blood and
everything just like a hammer movie and
he takes over there the bodies of the
people whose blood he drinks and he like
goes around in disguise and only the cop
I can see that he's actually a demon
yeah um but also there's a lot of
swearing yeah but then there's like leg
but nutty kid stuff but - but the thing
is is that I remember Japanese cartoons
you know like get a robo you know and
[ __ ] grand Iser they're very adult
themed yeah by Western standards I mean
you know they even kind of had nipples
on the girls yeah that's um you know I
mean so it was just a different standard
you know they they didn't evidently
worried about the same thing Western
audience is worried about they weren't
uptight they weren't very uptight but
what I like about this movie not only is
the movie fun to watch it is very kind
of dark and eerie and it has a very good
visual style if you see that old 1700s
Japanese art the way things are like
painted on the side so you know wall
Scrolls or you know little teacups and
[ __ ]
imagine Hammer horror trying to make a
movie in that motif that's what it's
like yeah there's a lot of Japanese
buildings and Japanese samurai and but
then in the background do you know what
I mean big tall mountains and Mount Fuji
and eerie kana mists and fogs and dam
monsters demons and the Japanese
monsters are to their traditional
monsters were unsettling it kind of
weird like a beautiful woman but chin
she turns around and on the back of us a
gigantic ugly face and instead of a big
nose got a big nose that ends in a hand
Japanese monster yeah that's um I was
looking up the mythology of that this
the one that's in the movie spooky or
fair is a little bit different than the
traditional one the traditional one is
called a food Akoo Chiana which means to
mouthed woman and she looks like a
normal woman except like underneath her
hair like her hair can kind of come out
like tentacles and then um in
traditional mythology she doesn't have a
whole face on the back of her head it's
just a mouth and that's the only one
that eats okay
like the hair picks up rice balls and
sticks them in the mouth in the back but
the the one that's in this moon
he actually just has a whole other face
like on the back of her head and I think
her hair like does crazy it makes a lot
of sense I mean you know you're a young
guy you know and you're you're in Japan
and a long time ago and you're looking
at some pretty girl you know and you're
going like man she looks good and then
you start worrying yeah what's wrong
with her see the back of her head you
know it's got all the hair and all that
what if she's hiding something on the
back of her head where there's another
face back there and then it's like this
paranoia
maybe guys it became a meme well but the
Japanese guys yeah they look good from
the front but behind behind all that
hair because you know they weren't they
didn't have a dating scene I don't think
you know in Korea that she's me in Japan
among the elites you know I think
there's a lot of prostitution but the
high-class girls she probably had to
marry him to get your hands on him so
you might lead you to believe that
something might be on wrong with some of
them well there must be something like
that because even even to the present
day if you see you know Asian or
particularly Japanese horror movies they
have an obsession with ghost women that
have this really long hair that hangs
over their face and stuff like that so
there must be a thing but the I was
gonna say that the traditional myth
about the two mouth woman is that she
married this guy and this guy's like wow
she hardly eats anything and it's like
I'm gonna save all this money cuz she
doesn't have much appetite but then he
started getting suspicious because he's
like well why is that that why doesn't
why don't ever see her eating anything
and so he like snuck out when like he
said he was by I'm going to work with
any luck he stayed and he spied on her
and then like her hair went like that
and her skull cracked open and there was
a mouse in there and it started like
stuff and rice into the and he was like
why you see these are manly fears it
makes perfect sense and I have you know
I hope you never find out about yourself
I have in the back of my head yeah
you're seeing this you're seeing this
hot chick right and you're eating it you
don't see her eating you know I mean
yeah it might eat a little bit of salad
or so you're like this can't be that
sounds not right worries start to worry
boy you're
can you talk to you brought to your boy
you're like dude you miss it they don't
eat because I'm [ __ ] going on with that
they're masters masters I think that's
what they're talking about I wonder if
like it really does seem like there's
that's a thread that goes through not
just Asian mythology but all mythology
that like somehow women are secretly
monsters yeah well men did a lot man did
a lot of men did a lot of the writing of
the books that's part of it and a lot of
them were kind of like I maybe like
bachelors or guys that maybe maybe they
weren't too popular with women you know
so maybe their experience with women
with pretty limited yeah they might have
been partly that's not what I mean look
at like [ __ ] like to make an explanation
identity and all that kind of stuff like
there's teeth in there oh here's these
spheres start coming out yeah that's
what I think what's going on versus
pride just mostly back dad you know but
I think the creepiest the creepiest
yokai in this movie is the woman with
the neck yeah that's like a ghost of
some yeah it's called Arikara Kuby which
means pulley Nick bully Nick yeah who
looks normal like she usually looks so
her she looks a little ghosty you know
what I mean like you know like one of
the you know Asian ghosts that like in
the garage or whatever but then she can
like extend her neck really far yeah
which is something for some reason that
would have scare a Japanese man and the
17 others well it's pretty um unsettling
looking I have to say I think what
they're trying to do is are trying to
evoke kind of like a reptilian snake
like yeah the quality something that
might in snare you and coil you up
around in her neck that's that's
probably what they're talking a few
snakes or even combining a woman and a
snake together and into an into a ghost
yeah to a ghost-like character but this
is a good movie it's just you know it's
got good style the the visuals and them
and the music is good the story's good
the characters are good it's kind of
like watching a tow hook Godzilla movie
but done with by Hammer horror and it's
the and for the most part the monsters
are
giant there human-sized until the very
end of course you know Dracula or the
vampire has to get giant well yeah
someone has to get big everybody gets
somebody go back and watch our big man
Japan yeah yeah
somebody goes oh yeah and all the
Japanese monsters have to figure out how
to how to foil this invading Western
monster yeah is how it's how it comes
like now I do like how the how the
vampires portrayed he's not a Bela
Lugosi type vampire where you know where
his form is that of a man his normal
form as this Babylon yeah he's a monster
dragon monster later on thing like Tia
ma were mixed together with some kind of
a demon that's his true form but he can
appears he can he can put an oar on
himself to appear as other people when
he drinks somebody's blood and kills
them he takes over their body and let's
Isis right which is kind of like an
alternate way of saying turning people
into the vampire slaves yeah except I
think he just pops from person to person
which that was something that was kind
of you know it's kind of cool about
vampire stories and Anne Rice kind of
had that in there where Lestat made
other vampires to kind of serve him and
she got that from actually the part two
of scream bat black of the screen yeah
and I've seen the original cut and the
slavery scene is in the original but
it's not in my blu-ray copy and it's not
in it was cut from that movie yes and it
was a great scene and it's I guess
because they didn't want slavery to come
up in a blaxploitation move you want to
call it a blaxploitation I don't think
it's black a black product movie I
didn't didn't make any sense to me
Buchan Blacula turns this [ __ ] dude
this black dude into a vampire when he
comes to he's like a halt man look at me
let's go out tonight because you will do
no such thing
oh so you will go to the club and show
off your vampire skills they will come
back here and kill us all you know and
he's like yeah but I stayed here because
you're my slave and that's it
yeah you will do what I tell you I will
destroy you and [ __ ] that was a that
was
the [ __ ] really the essence of these
vampires was in a way slavery yeah
you bite a [ __ ] and turn him
into a vampire but not to empower him
between slave him yes you gotta have
your little minion so you could have
your minions and now is that was [ __ ]
beautiful I wish they had to cut that
out of Blacula
but that went right into the [ __ ]
hand Rice's novels yeah when she didn't
make it so explicit but that's what it
was
yeah pretty much right but yeah so I do
like that you can see like this is I'm
not gonna lie this is a weird movie if
you like like weird Japanese cinema this
is one of the weirder ones all of the
monsters though look pretty cool it's
not they're not done with them you know
it's it's mostly like people in costumes
or puppets I think the the umbrella
monster is above it it's like a
marionette and [ __ ] like that so it's
just like this really weird I saw like
cinemassacre I think he compared it a
little bit too he's like you know it's a
weird Japanese think it's the same
studio that did the Gamera movies yeah
you know I mean although it's not better
whoo it's it's a dying or whatever yeah
so it's the same one so it's not like as
it's not as terrible equality is that
might imply because the Gamera movie
there were them we're pretty bad but you
know still fun though I mean a wacky
monsters and stuff this one is alike a
lot more traditional you know samurai
period kind of thing with just some
monsters in it but cinema guidance in a
massacre compared it a little bit
he said it's kind of the tone of it is
kind of like a Sid and Marty Krofft
thing like Lidz Vil or something like
that we're just like this really weird
like not exactly but that's probably the
closest Western equivalent because it's
like it's it seems like it's marginally
for kids but then it's like really kind
of dark as well like it's bloody there's
bad language it's like you know what I'm
a it's it's not scary scary but it's
like kind of creepy like some of the
yokai are kind of creepy even though
they're all good guys even the ones that
traditionally because I think like the
Kappa in Japanese folklore I mean
they're usually known for like dragging
little children down into the river
dragging people down in the river and
killing them but in this one he's like
friendly
like he helps out the kids and
everything like he tries to beat up a
vampire and everything but they so it's
it's kind of cool that you have like all
these little yokai monsters and they're
all trying to like get together to like
to defeat this enemy who is she like
stronger than pretty much all of them
put together and they don't feel like
work together any foreigners they know
nothing about vampire lore they don't
know if vampires weaknesses or its
abilities or how to kill it yeah and how
they kill it in the end couldn't have
killed a vampire vampire lore is true it
must have survived because what what
they thought was what they thought would
kill a vampire is not in any vampire
lord yeah they thought that if you
attacked its eyes yeah that that would
kill it there are nothing about a stake
through the heart nothing about sunlight
nothing nothing like that but that was
nothing they could come up with and I
kind of feel like because even though
that's an open yeah even though the the
demon or the demon as they call him
that's his name I guess um even though
he has vampire characteristics in that
he drinks blood and stuff he's sure he's
not like a vampire vampire and he's not
like a Western vampire vampire yeah I
mean but he has like other kind of [ __ ]
that he can do like he can clone himself
he can make himself giant he can like
take over other people's bodies like a
like an even more like a demon than a
vampire yay
I guess it's real close to a vampire it
is yeah I mean being able to confuse
your enemies you're turning into a bunch
of rats that's kind of like becoming
making multiple copies of your caucus
use well it was an illusion anyway there
were only yeah that's true only one of
them was the real him so vampires could
create illusions evidently so that kind
of matches getting big might just have
just been an illusion oh yeah yeah I
mean he didn't pry he probably didn't
really get big so they didn't I didn't
really understand what they were dealing
with what else did what else did he oh
and another thing is taking over people
and possessing other people that might
have also been an illusion that might
have been him impersonating a person
he could impersonate people yeah but
nobody could see through it except the
kappa the copper could see through it he
could see who they really was and he
didn't make them vampires but what
happened to the people that he possessed
did they're just dead yeah they died
yeah because the first guy like um cuz
that's kind of like making a slave
vampire yeah I kind of felt like it was
weird because it's almost like it's a
different interpretation of what a
vampire might yeah because didn't it
like the first guy that he killed like
that magistrate guy or whatever it's
like killing Amos he left the body there
but then like he took the body but I
think that the body was still there cuz
wasn't there one scene where like we do
out I think he killed the bot it killed
that guy and then didn't he go into that
guy's body yeah and then animate it yeah
that's what I thought happened but he
could only I guess he could only be in
one body at once because when he moved
from one to another like when he killed
another guy like he moved into that body
and then that guy was just laying there
dead okay that's that body and that body
fell down right or so yeah I think so I
think that's how it went
yeah it didn't that's how I remembered
it didn't really underscore this whole
process they just kind of rolled with it
yeah like I don't remember them ever
showing what they did with that body did
they bury it and did it come back to
life yes because there's no there's not
like a hell of a lot of human characters
in this movie it's just basically just
this one little village right and then
there's like the first guy that gets
killed and then like his daughter or
whatever and then there's like another
samurai and there's a couple other
people but it's mostly and a couple of
little kids that like the vampires
trying to get but it's mostly about the
monsters yeah in terms of the vampire
and its powers the way I was
interpreting it interpreted it over the
[ __ ] years of watching the movie and
of course I didn't read into this [ __ ]
too much and I mean I just watched it I
don't think I the way I was taking it is
that he was drinking people's blood that
was killing them yeah okay and that all
that others should the use
was actually more like an illusion yeah
like a glamour like a glamour because
when he fought his illusions fought the
monsters but they knew that those
weren't really the real ones they were
trying to find the real one yeah and
then when they found the real one it was
kind of a traditional fight yeah he did
get big that didn't seem to help him as
if getting big was just an illusion well
see I wonder about them because then the
Umbrella monster they had to fly up
there because the umbrella monster can
fly yeah
and he had to like kind of like ride up
on the Roadster to get up to his eyeball
so I guess he really did get big yeah
but it didn't seem to help him it didn't
make him more massive or more strong you
wouldn't smash in any of them he wasn't
like he didn't get stronger when he got
big you just got to see the movie for
yourself
I forgot that he could also turn into a
storm like a thunderstorm yeah cuz he
did that at the beginning that's how he
first came to because he could fly
backwards yeah yeah and I will I think I
kind of thought that he turned into that
maybe either that or it was a power and
he could like make a storm all around
him because remember like at the very
beginning like the magistrate was
fighting him but he was fighting the
storm like he's swinging his sword at
the wind or that make sense when you
look at it from the point of view that
you have Japanese people in the 60s okay
trying to make up a vampire character
that is more ancient than a Bela Lugosi
vampire yeah this thing I think supposed
to be much older than that yeah so
within the vampire lore they're saying
well it's like a demon and it's in and
it came from you and they call it a
daemon yeah that's what they call yeah
and it's it's it's a daemon and it comes
from you know Mesopotamia somewhere it's
good acting batshit up and so all the
little all the little cute / scary
monsters have to fight against I mean
what we thought was the baby ghost a
little oil presser guy yeah I think he
might be my favorite yeah just because I
love his little face and especially I
like at the end like when they're all
going into the final battle or whatever
he has his little this little headband
or whatever on this big like baby
yes had his hat is it silly he's about
the size of a kid of a child Yeah right
like a 4 or 5 year old kid its how big
he is but his head is Prior like size of
a small garbage can yeah it's like a
baby unit like a huge Dam beach ball
yeah yeah and I feel like there's like
it I kind of want to watch like it's an
awfully dark as it came out in the 60s
and so you know it's the film quality
it's like kind of dark and stuff but
it's like I always kind of like wanted
to just pause all the [ __ ] because like
at the end of the battle when all the
yokai are going they're doing their
little parade or whatever cuz they won
there's like a zillion of them in there
and it's like there's only like a
handful that are really featured and
have speaking parts and stuff but the
fact that they had to make all of those
costumes for all of those people and
they weren't even gonna be like you
could even barely see them yeah and it
came down from the heavens yeah it looks
like a lot of the warfare happened
everything that the backgrounds blacked
out so it's kind of happening and in the
spirit realm - yeah and then it faded
away and they went back up towards Mount
Fuji look cuz I guess the monsters are
kind of like monsters but they're also
kind of goes their spiritual yeah their
spiritual monsters yeah so like I said
this is part of a trilogy the other two
it's not really like a trilogy in the
sense of like being a continuing story
or anything they're pretty standalone as
I said the other two are more human
centric yeah and they're just okay and
yeah so I didn't like those as much make
it there they're not like his fond or as
weird as just one [ __ ] crazy but
something I didn't know play this one at
the club yeah one night where I was a DJ
booth [ __ ] playing this and I was
doing weird [ __ ] with the videos it was
going on everybody's watching yokai wars
yokai monsters then afterwards they
loved it people yeah I think you showed
it to me um [ __ ] not too long after we
first met I think I was over at your
house and you were to show it to me I'm
like that's the craziest [ __ ] ever ever
so yeah it's a crazy movie something I
didn't know what I was like looking this
up is that I guess in 2005 famed
Japanese director Takashi me
a maid I don't know if it's like a soft
reboot or like a new version of this and
it's called the great yokai war um and I
think I kind of have to see it now cuz I
really really like that director but
yeah he's I don't know if it's like
exactly like a remake per se or if he
just made another story like with the
same yokai monsters type of thing I
think is based on a manga actually like
they came out around the same time this
is a good one just because the
characters are mostly monsters and yes
[ __ ] bizarre ass character designs
and [ __ ] crazy costumes and weird
[ __ ] happens and it's very
straightforward and it's just like
watching a Godzilla movie or something
yeah except I I thought a better loved I
thought it was a lot more fun because it
was the monsters were a lot more like
humanized yeah and the colors and the
color palettes just in the way
everything's shots real soft and it
looks kind of like it's like a painting
from the 1700 Tokugawa Japan so it looks
like yeah it's super cold yeah but um I
think it's probably I think the DVDs we
have the whole trilogy like I'm not sure
how when you got them but we've had them
for a while um I think they might be out
of print but you might be able to still
get them somewhere like rush me or
Amazon I would think and you know if
it's that hard to get then maybe
somebody uploaded it to YouTube or
something like that but um you know I
don't think there's any extras or
anything like that on there no on the
discs they're very very very bare bare
bone bare bones I want to say but yeah
if you can find the [ __ ] you know watch
all three of them if you're into that
kind of stuff but I mean I think this is
spook warfare I think is the best one
just because it's the wackiest and I
really literally the best yeah and I
really like like all the little monster
designs and stuff like that so yeah um
you know if you've never seen it then
and you like weird Asian movies then you
definitely definitely need to seek this
one out